[موسيقى]
مساء الخير هو من ابرز الوجوه الشيعيه
الداعيه لنبذ العنف والتحريض الطائفي ومن
دعاه الحوار والعيش المشترك بين المسلمين
والمسيحيين ومن دعاه الوحده الاسلاميه
والحوار بين المذاهب والاديان له مواقف
صريحه ضد تصدير ولايه الفقيه الى شعوب
المنطقه ويدعو الى حصرها داخل ايران
العلامه اللبنانيه السيد علي الامين
المرجع الديني الشيعي البارز وعضو مجلس
حكماء المسلمين في سؤال مباشر سيد علي
اهلا وسهلا بك معي على شاشه العربيه في
سؤال مباشر
اهلا وسهلا بكم وانا لكم من الشاكرين
وشاكر لقناه العربيه على هذه الاستضافه
سيبدا معك بالعنوان الابرز والاهم اليوم
في المنطقه سيد علي وهنا تحدث تحديدا عن
الاتفاق او التفاهم السعودي الايراني
المستجد
الاتفاق في عنوانه الابرز جاء
بهدف اعاده العلاقات الدبلوماسيه بين
الدولتين الجارتين وفتح السفارات
والممثليات التي اغلقت قبل سنوات لكن
تاثيراته بالتاكيد ستكون بشكل مباشر او
غير مباشر على المنطقه بشكل عام اريد ان
ابدا معك بتعليقك او قراءتك وجهه نظرك حول
هذا الاتفاق الذي اعلنت قبل ايام
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم يعني نحن للحقيقه
كنا من المسرورين بهذا الاتفاق
ونسال الله سبحانه وتعالى
ان يتم سرورنا بتنفيذه
وعوده الامور الى طبيعتها بين دوله ايران
وبين المملكه العربيه السعوديه
وبين ايران والمنطقه عموما نحن كنا من
الدعاه يعني قديما
الى ان تكون ايران مصدر طمانينه لجيرانها
من العرب
وبذلك
يعني تفتح
هذه المنطقه منطقه الخليج
بوابه ايران على العالم العربي ولا يوجد
من جيرانها من يشكل تهديدا لها لكن
هل له اصل بالنسبه
لايران اليوم هذا الاتفاق يعني بناء على
ماذا تم في وجهه نظر النظام الايراني
برايك
يعني انا اعتقد ان ايران اقتنعت بانه لابد
من عوده الامور الى طبيعتها مع جيرانها
مقدمه الى دخولها في المنظومه الدوليه
وعوده العلاقات الى المجتمع الدولي من
خلال هذه التجربه التي نامل نجاحها
وادركت ايران بان السياسه التي اعتمدت
يعني في العقود الماضيه هي سياسه
يعني ادت الى
مشاكل لها مع العالم ومع محيطها وفي
الداخل ايضا
ونامل يعني ان تكون هذه هي
الاسباب التي
ادت الى تسريع مثل هذا الاتفاق بين
المملكه العربيه السعوديه وبين الجمهوريه
الاسلاميه في ايران
لكنك سيد علي ربما من اكثر المعارضين
وكذلك ربما المتضررين من سلوك النظام
الايراني في المنطقه بشكل عام وفي لبنان
خصوصا
اليوم عندما يتوجه النظام الايراني بهذه
الخطوه نحو الاتفاق مع المملكه العربيه
السعوديه باعاده العلاقات في هذا التوقيت
وهو النظام القائم في دستوره على تصدير
الثوره على الدعم الميليشيات المسلحه على
كذلك ولايه الفقيه على مبدا التقيه كما
يرى الكثير ربما الا يجعلنا ننظر الى هذا
الامور والى هذا الاتفاق وهذا التوجه
الايراني بمنظر الشك والريبه
يعني انا اعتقد ان
الايران استفادت من تجارب الماضي
السياسه التي اعتمدت في الماضي
سواء يعني في المنطقه العربيه او مع
العالم
مع كثير من دول العالم
ادركت بانها سياسه مضره وغير منتجه وغير
مفيده
والقاعده تقول والصلح خير
وطبعا هذا التلاقي بين يعني الجمهوريه
الاسلاميه في ايران وبين المملكه العربيه
السعوديه
اذا تم ان شاء الله سيكون له اصداء
ايجابيه واثار ايجابيه في المنطقه كلها
وفي العلاقات بين عموم المسلمين
فيما بينهم يعني ولذلك ما يسمى بمبدا
التقيه يعني التقيه في السياسه موجوده في
العالم ككل يعني ليست خصوصيه
ايرانيه
موجوده من يمكن ان يقترح شيئا وان يخالفه
ولكن دائما الحكم يكون يعني على الاعمال
وهو من خلال
ترجمتها للاقوال
ونحن يعني
نتفاءل خيرا بان هناك تغييرا في السياسات
التي
احدثت مثل هذه الفرقه بين المسلمين في هذه
المنطقه وفي غيرها لكن هل يمكن الوثوق
بنوايا هذا النظام الذي تمتد ذروعه
وميليشياته في المنطقه تسيطر على اربع
عواصم عربيه انت كنت ربما ترى بانها هي
السبب في انهيار هذه البلدان انهيار
الامني لانهيار الاقتصادي لانهيار السياسي
وغيره يعني هل يمكن ان نثق بهذه بهذا
النظام في توجهاته وبهذه الميليشيات هل
يمكن خاصه الاتفاق هناك بنود سريه غير
معلنه فيه لكن هل يمكن ان تتغير سلوك هذه
الميليشيات في المنطقه اليوم بعد هذا
الاتفاق ام انه مجرد
تغير في التكتيك فقط ربما للتهدئه كما
يقول البعض ترقبا لما يمكن ان يحدث من
تطورات اخرى على مستوى العالم
يعني نحن الان لا يمكننا ان نحكم على
النوايا
وانما نحكم من خلال الممارسات وما
سيحدث بعد تنفيذ هذه البنود
وانا متفائل بانه ستتغير الكثير من الامور
لان ايران قد ادركت يعني بانما كان من
اسباب الفرقه بينها وبين
جيرانها واشقائها في العالم العربي
والاسلامي هو تلك السياسه
التي اعتمدت منطق الازرع
المسلحه في اكثر من منطقه
وهي لم تنتج الا مزيدا من الخصومات
والعداوات التي اضرت
بالعلاقات الاسلاميه
وبالمنطقه ككل
انا متفائل بان هناك
تغييرا سيحدث ان شاء الله من خلال هذا
الاتفاق
وعلى قاعده تفائل بالخير تجدوه
خلينا نفكر او نحاول ان نقرا ما هي
التداعيات وتاثيرات هذا الاتفاق على هذه
الميليشيات او الاذرع المسلحه الموجوده في
المنطقه
سواء في البعد في البعد الاديولوجي او في
البعد كذلك
التغول في داخل هذه الدول القوميه او
الوطنيه ولنضرب على سبيل المثال اولا
ميليشيا الحوتي في اليمن كيف سيتغير الامر
بالنسبه لهذه الميليشيا في اليمن اليوم
وعلى مستوى العلاقه بين النظام الايراني
الذي وقع هذا الاتفاق
وسلوك هذه الميليشيات مستقبلا ما نشاهده
في اليمن وفي لبنان وفي غيرها
ان تلك الازرع يعني انشات حروبا داخليه
وصراعات داخليه
واضعفت الدول
الحل الذي يمكن ان يزيل مثل هذه
النتائج التي شاهدناها والتي لا تزال
قائمه هو اندماج تلك الاذر على المسلحه في
مشروع في مشاريع دولها ان تندمج وان تصبح
خاضعه
[موسيقى]
لمنطق الدوله
وان تصبح علاقات ايران مع من دوله الى
دوله وليس من خلال هذه الاحزاب ومن خلال
تلك الاذرع والمنظمات
ينبغي وهذا ما كنا نطلبه قديما ان المطلوب
من ايران ان تتعاطى مع لبنان او مع العراق
او مع اليمن ان تتعاطى مع دولي تلك
الشعوب مباشره وليس من خلال احزاب
وتنظيمات وجمعيات طيب اسمح لي ان اقف معك
عند هذا الفاصل القصير نعود بعده سيد علي
للحوار في سؤال مباشر فاصل ونعود الي
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد ضيفي في سؤال مباشر هو
العلامه اللبناني السيد علي الامين المرجع
الدين الشيعي عضو مجلس حكماء المسلمين
اهلا وسهلا بك سيد علي تعودنا على صراختك
لكن في اجاباتك السابقه كنت
دبلوماسيا بشكل كبير ساذهب معك الى تاثير
هذا الاتفاق
على المستقبل السياسي في لبنان لبنان
تعاني كثيرا على كل المستويات وعلى كل
الاصايده سيد علي ما الذي سيحدث في لبنان
بعد هذا الاتفاق ودعني يعني استشهد هنا
ربما بما قاله السيد حسن نصر الله منعم
حزب الله في تعليقه الاول على هذا الاتفاق
قال سعداء باستئناف العلاقات بين الرياض
وطهران ولدينا ثقه فان ذلك سيكون لمصلحه
شعوب المنطقه كيف تقرا هذا التعليق
يعني هذه كما قلنا بدايه التغيير في
اللغه التي كان يستخدمها حزب الله
واعتقد يعني هم يصرحون طبعا
بانهم تابعون
للولي الفقيه في ايران ولارشاداته
والتوجيهاته
ويتلقون منه الاوامر ولذلك عندما ينجح مثل
هذا الاتفاق
اعتقد بان يعني بان حزب الله سيغير سياسته
وسيطيع
القياده الايرانيه في مشروع الاندماج في
مشروع الدوله
وعندئذ تتغير الامور تعتقد ان حزب الله
مستقبلا سيندمج سيتنازل في الدخول مع نظام
سياسي وطني في لبنان سيد علي
طبعا اعتقد لانه هو اذا يعني
ذلك هل تلمس اي مؤشرات اليوم في على القلب
في بدايه هذه الايام وان كان الحكم مبكرا
على هذا الامر
يعني ما اسمعه طبعا من
من
يعني مؤيدي حزب الله ومن قيادات حزب الله
نسمع هناك ثناء ومديحا لهذا الاتفاق وهذا
انكشف عن شيء انهم يكشف عن انهم يمكن ان
يتغيروا وان
يطبق يعني ما ينتج عن هذا الاتفاق من
سياسات في المنطقه وفي لبنان بالخصوص طبعا
هل تعتقد ان حزب الله في لبنان الذي يحكم
ربما كما يرى الكثير بالحديد والنار الان
وقادر على ان يتنازل عن مصالحه عن
مكتسباته كما يعتقد بالتحكم في القرار
السياسي في لبنان الى درجه ان تسلب منه
هذه
المكانه يعني خلال فتره لمجرد اتفاق موقع
او اطار اتفاق موقع بين نظام الايراني
وبين السعوديه
يعني هو هذه المكانه اخذها من خلال
ارتباطه
بالرؤيه الايرانيه
وهي مكانه يعني جعلته منبوذا داخليا ليس
مقبولا داخليا يعني معظم اللبنانيين لا
يرتضون مثل هذه الاشياء
فعندما هو يعود ليندمج في مشروع الدوله
يصبح مقبولا ويتخلى عن سلاحه
ويندمش في مشروع الدوله ويصبح السلاح جزءا
من من الدوله اللبنانيه وخاضعا لرؤيه
الدوله اللبنانيه وبذلك هو يعني
انت تعرف حزب الله وتعرف تاريخ حزب الله
وسياسه حزب الله وتفكير حزب الله يعني هل
من الوارد فعلا بان يسلم سلاحه ويندمج مع
نظام السياسي الوطني في لبنان
نعم يندمج عندما تطلب منه ايران ذلك اذا
اذا نجح الاتفاق في ايران ستطلب منه ذلك
وسيكون هناك تخريج لعمليه الاندماج كيف
تتوقع ان يكون تاثير هذا الامر على
العلاقه بين طائفتين السنيه والشيعيه في
المنطقه سيد علي
هذا سينعكس طبعا ايجابا وسيعزز روابط
الوحده والالفه بين عموم المسلمين
يعني بين السنه والشيعه الذين هم امه
واحده وانما احدثت هذه الخلافات فيما
بينهم
تلك النزاعات
والخلافات بين الانظمه السياسيه وبين
الاحزاب السياسيه فالان عندما يعني يتفق
رمضان من رموز الامه الاسلاميه المملكه
العربيه السعوديه التي تعتبر مرجعيه
لعموم المسلمين
لمكان لمكانه المقدسات فيها التي
يلتقي فيها كل المسلمين على اختلاف
مذاهبهم مع ايران ايضا ذات المكانه
الدينيه
للطائفه وفي
اعتقد بان هذا سيدخل السرور على عموم
المسلمين لانه سيحدث المزيد من الالفا
والتقارب فيما بين ابناء الامه الواحده
هناك جدل دائم ترتفع وتنخفض حدته سيد علي
حسب يعني الظروف المحيطه مثلا وياخذ صيغه
مذهبيه بين المسلمين بين الطائفتين السنيه
والشيعه مؤخرا كان هناك جدل واختلاف حول
مسلسل معاويه بن ابي سفيان الذي من
المفترض ان يعرض على الشاشه
هذا الجده او هذا الخلاف اسبابه من وجهه
نظرك ياسباب دينيه اما اسباب سياسيه
يعني انا اعتقد انه لو كانت لو كان المناخ
السياسي الذي يوجد في بين المسلمين هو
يعني كان مناخا طبيعيا لما حدثت مثل هذه
الاختلافات
وهذه يعني النزاعات حول مثل هذه القضايا
هي قضايا في اغلب الاحيان تتدخل فيها
السياسه
خصوصا يعني ان
من يختلفون عليه لم يكن في عصرهم يعني سنه
وشيعه لم يكن في عصر معاويه ابن ابي سفيان
وفي عهد علي ابن ابي طالب سنه وشيعه وانما
كان هناك موالات ومعارضه فما كان هناك
حاله مذهبيه فاذا
اسقاط الحاله المذهبيه المتاخره عليها
ليست صحيحه لانها كانت سابقه على عهد
المذاهب
عفوا سيدي علي يمكن اكبر عقبه تواجه
اي محاولات او مبادرات للحوار والتفاهم
بين السنه او الشيعه هي مساله سب الصحابه
وسب وسب ام المؤمنين عائشه وهو امر يجرح
يعني عامه المسلمين ويزيد الفرقه انت ترفض
ذلك تماما
هذا التطاول يعني
والسب على على الصحابه وعلى على الخلفاء
الراشدين
كيف يجوز في وجهه نظر البعض اليوم من
يتبنون هذا الموقف ولا يخالف ذلك الحاله
السائده التي يجب ان يكون عليها كل
المسلمين في العالم
يعني هذه طبعا كما قلنا حاله يمكن
ليست حاله عامه يعني وانما هي عندما ولدت
هذه الاحزاب
الدينيه في عصرنا
حملت معها مثل هذه الامور من اجل ان تجذب
الاتباع والانصار اليها والا نحن انا اذكر
عندما كنا يعني في العراق
لم نكن نسمع بهذه الامور يعني ليست هي
بندا من البنود الدينيه او عندما كنا في
لبنان في بيئتنا وفي اجواءنا
لم نعش مثل هذه الحاله التي تبنتها فيما
بعد يعني احزاب كما قلنا من اجل ان تجرب
اليها الاتباع والانصار
كلنا نحن مامورون بان يعني
نتبع
الائمه اهل البيت
الذي كان يقول امامهم علي بن ابي طالب اني
اكره لكم ان تكونوا سبابين عندما سمع
جماعه من اصحابه يسبون في عند
حرب الشام
قال لهم اني اكره لكم ان تكونوا سبابين
فلذلك هذه يعني امور
لم تكن وارده في
قواميس اهل البيت وائمه اهل البيت
ولذلك يعني العموم يجتنبونها لكن يمكن ان
لابد ان يبقى اشخاص مثلا قد يحملون مثل
هذه يعني العقليه
التي فيها لا تخلو من التعصب ومن الابتعاد
عن المبادئ الدينيه التي تدعو الى الاحسان
والى المحبه والى التسامح والى احترام
الرموز الدينيه لكل المذاهب والطوائف
والاديان السيد علي استضفتم في مقركم في
بيروت مؤخرا اعضاء منصه الحوار من مركز
الملك العالمي للحوار بين الاديان
والثقافات ضم هذا اللقاء ممثلين عن مختلف
القيادات الدينيه في ارجاء العالم العربي
بشكل سريع كيف تصف هذا اللقاء هل يمكن
بالفعل يعني لهذه يعني الشخصيات هؤلاء
الممثلين ان يقفوا على مبدا واحد في وحده
المسلمين بكل المذاهبهم واديانهم وطوائفهم
يعني خلال هذه الفتره وضع قواعد معينه
تتفق عليها كل الاطراف لصالح المسلمين
يعني انا الحقيقه في هذا اللقاء الذي
جمعني مع
اعضاء هذه المنصه من كايصيد مركز الملك
عبدالله رحمه الله
كنت في غايه السرور لانني رايت يعني
مجموعه
متضامنه
يجمعها حب الله سبحانه وتعالى
وكان مركز الملك عبدالله رحمه الله
يعني هو السباق الى هذه
الى هذه الصيغه التي تجمع
اهل الديانات والحوار والثقافات
ووجدت فيها نموذجا يعني
سابقا لكل ما حصل فيما بعد لانه كان سباق
فعلا مركز
الى مثل هذه اللقاءات ومثل هذه الاجتماعات
بين القيادات الدينيه والدعوه الى الحوار
لمختلف الثقافات والمذاهب والطوائف
فهذا النموذج يعني هو اصبح فيما بعد
يدعى اليه عالميا في كل المنتديات وفي
كثير من الدول
اعتمدوا هذا المنهج الذي بناه مركز الملك
عبد الله في فيينا رحمه الله
فهذا النموذج يعني
يمكن ان يتسع وان يعني يؤثر لانه ينشر
ثقافه الحوار والتواصل والمحبه والتلاقي
وذكرني يعني
اجتماعهم على اختلاف مذاهبهم واجيانهم
وثقافاتهم
ذكرني بالحديث الشريف الذي يقول
المتحابون في الله على منابر في يوم
القيامه او انهم يدخلون الجنه بغير حساب
هذا النموذج جمعته المحبه في الله وفي
الانسانيه هذا يمكن ان نعقد عليه الامال
الكبيره في نشر خطاب المحبه لمواجهه خطاب
الكراهه وثقافتها سيد علي شكرا جزيلا لك
على تواجدك معنا في هذه الحلقه من سؤال
مباشر
لكم الشكر الجزيل حفظكم الله ورعاكم وشكرا
لكم ولقناه العربيه
الحلقه ايضا من سؤال مباشر كان معنا في
السيد علي الامين المرجع الديني شاهد
ومجلس حكماء المسلمين دائما يمكنكم
متابعتنا على مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي
تويتر فيسبوك ويوتيوب ومشاهده هذه الحلقه
والاستماعة اليها على شاهدوا على العربيه
بالكاستيلا